bonsoir Patrice on a vu très rapidement
là les sept travaux on va les prendre
presque tous un à un mais de manière
générale on voit là les revaloriser le
français formation écourtée aide à la
classe projet pédagogique particulier
formation professionnelle accès aux
données et rénovation des écoles on va y
revenir mais de manière générale vous
avez dit quelque chose dans la
conférence de presse de Eddy vous savez
on met 20 milliards ou presque là-dedans
donc ça devrait mieux marcher
surtout qu'on devrait mieux savoir à
quoi l'argent sert et quel résultat on
obtient avec cet investissement là c'est
la question des données l'accès à
l'information actuellement on a 72
centres de services scolaire et
commission scolaire au Québec et
honnêtement Patrice c'est compliqué de
savoir ce qui se passe et je blâme pas
les centres de service scolaire pour ça
il y a des investissements à faire au
niveau des des technologies de
l'information au niveau des systèmes
informatiques pour qu'on sache ce qui se
passe dans les écoles enfin qu'il faut
un lien beaucoup plus efficace entre le
ministère et les centres de services
puis entre les centres de service puis
les écoles parce que 80% du budget dont
vous parlez Patrice c'est des salaires
alors à partir de ce moment-là qu'est-ce
que tu veux tu envoies ça dans les
écoles et puis là il faut savoir est-ce
que ça fonctionne ou ça fonctionne pas
quels sont les résultats qu'on obtient
avec cet investissement là puis
actuellement en tout cas certaines
données là beaucoup de données
honnêtement on a de la difficulté à
savoir ce qui se passe donc moi j'ai dû
j'ai un travail à faire avec les centres
de services puis avec les écoles pour
savoir ce qui se passe exactement puis
avec la bonne information après ça
prendre les bonnes décisions votre
collègue à la santé que son tableau de
bord le camion en place qui va se
développer avait dit ce qui se mesure
s'améliore on vous a demandé aujourd'hui
combien manque de profs vous avez dit je
le sais pas
ce qui est fou je veux dire la première
fois qu'on me dit ça Patrice là
la journée la rencontre moi je rencontre
mes summénistes pour la première fois là
puis là on me dit
monsieur le ministre on n'est pas
capable de vous dire combien de
personnes travaillent dans le réseau
scolaire parce qu'on n'a pas les données
où on a des données mais elles sont pas
comparables d'un centre de service à
l'autre fait que au jour d'aujourd'hui
je suis pas capable de vous dire
exactement combien de personnes
travaillent dans le réseau puis vous
avez raison de faire la comparaison avec
Christian Dubé a bien des égards c'est
la même opération que je dois faire avec
mes 72 centres de services scolaire et
mes 3000 quelques écoles que j'ai au
Québec bon
alors on va prendre quelques-unes de vos
priorités la première vous avez bon
revalorisé l'enseignement du français on
va appeler ça plus simplement mieux
enseigner le français on a vu les
résultats
d'examens j'en parlais au Premier
ministre hier oui il y a eu la pandémie
mais quand même les lumières rouges sont
allumées les jeunes apprennent moins à
écrire et à bien lire le français à
composer là vous avez un objectif mais
comment il y a pas de comment après
avoir dit ça
exact puis je vais devoir vous revenir
Patrice avec ça
jongle avec un certain nombre d'idées
puis de scénarios
par exemple
c'est normal que dans une classe de
français quand l'exercice est terminé
puis que les élèves remettent leur copie
c'est normal que le prof de français
corrige les fautes en français bon mais
moi je pense que c'est pas juste en
français qu'on devrait corriger les
fautes de français moi je pense que je
vais pas me péton dans le cours
d'histoire ou dans le cours de Éthique
et culture religieuse qui va devenir
culture et citoyenneté moi je pense
qu'on devrait corriger les fautes
systématiquement pour que les élèves
sachent qu'ils ont fait des fautes puis
qui doivent travailler là-dessus sur le
français écrit je dis pas qu'il faut
sanctionner systématiquement oui il faut
le faire mais s'agit pas de couler
systématiquement tous les élèves parce
qu'ils font des fautes mais au fond il
faut au moins les informer leur dire
garde il y a un problème là ici avec ta
grand-mère ton orthographe pour que les
élèves s'améliorent alors est-ce que
c'est rétroaction là se fait
systématiquement dans notre système
scolaire
j'en suis pas convaincu Patrice il y a
du travail à faire là dessus puis quand
je serai quand j'aurai un portrait plus
complet de la situation mais je vais
arriver avec des propositions de
solution est-ce que il y aura des
projets pilotes dans votre esprit qu'on
peut mettre rapidement sur pied pour
tester une nouvelle façon de faire pour
mieux enseigner le français allez-vous
par exemple aller voyager ou ça aller
voir ce qui se passe dans la
francophonie dans les Français ils ont
plein de problèmes avec leur
hiérarchie puis leur appareil
gouvernemental mais ils apprennent le
français bien avez-vous êtes-vous en
mission là pour trouver toutes les
bonnes idées sa planète
je l'écarte pas mais vous savez la
popularité que les voyages ministériels
ont de
c'est mettons qu'avant d'aller à
l'étranger il y a des experts au Québec
que je dois rencontrer qui ont des
propositions à me faire et puis je vais
d'abord évaluer ce qu'on peut faire de
mieux à partir des idées qui sont chez
nous il y en a des bonnes idées qui sont
chez nous j'ai déjà des gens qui m'ont
écrit pour me dire garde il y a telle
personne qui s'y connaît très bien en la
matière tu devrais la rencontrer etc
donc on est en réflexion active
là-dessus mais je suis conscient du fait
que j'ai une obligation de soumettre
assez rapidement des propositions de
chacun du concret le taux de diplôme le
taux diplomation ça traverse un peu
toutes vos propositions il faut au
Québec monter le taux de diplomation des
garçons on va voir un tableau au Québec
on est en retard on est la province
canadienne où les garçons le moins de
taux de diplomation études secondaires
par rapport à l'Ontario 90 les garçons
les filles 87 les filles ça va beaucoup
mieux au Québec les garçons ont un
problème ça
comment on fait qu'est-ce qu'on fait
quel est votre objectif
si on pouvait au moins combler une
partie de l'écart avec les filles ce
serait déjà beaucoup mais je vais vous
dire moi je pense qu'avec les projets
particuliers l'idée d'implanter des
projets particuliers dans toutes les
écoles secondaires publiques du Québec
je pense que c'est
ça peut être une mesure qui peut
favoriser la motivation scolaire de tous
les élèves mais en particulier des
garçons puis je les dis aujourd'hui
Patrice il faut investir davantage dans
la formation professionnelle puis il
faut surtout la valoriser il faut dire
on est content d'avoir des diplômés
universitaires des diplômés du collégial
puis des diplômés du secondaire mais il
faut dire aussi un diplôme en formation
professionnelle un diplôme pour un
métier c'est très bon c'est très beau
puis je pense que
c'est une voie intéressante pour les
garçons pas juste les garçons parce que
des filles qui veulent aller en
formation technique puis dans les
métiers mais on connaît tous autour de
nous des gars qui sont plus des manuels
comme on dit puis je le dis en tout
respect honnêtement bien sûr je pour moi
c'est bon alors il faut il faut
valoriser la formation professionnelle
ça fait des années qu'on le dit mais on
le fait pas enfin on le fait pas assez
puis je vous le dis là on va donner un
méchant coup de barre en formation
professionnelle puis je veux faire des
gros investissements pour moderniser
cette formation là pour faire en sorte
notamment que les élèves en particulier
les garçons restent à l'école plutôt que
de céder à la tentation de prendre de
lâcher l’école puis de s'en aller
travailler dans une entreprise
tu as des entrepreneurs qui disent
garder mon gars viens étant chez nous je
vais te payer puis je vais te former
avec les plus belles machines que tu
verras pas dans le centre de formation
professionnelle mais mon travail c'est
de m'assurer que nos centres de
formation professionnelle il y a des
belles machines justement pour qu'on
soit capable de conc plus facile privé
parce que beaucoup de gens puissent au
débat des chefs les gens vous le
connaissez le débat les gens disent
c'est l'école à trois vitesses au Québec
les gens disent on le voit quand le
privé d'un côté et colle au milieu avec
des projets particuliers au public puis
lorsqu'il reste c'est les les écoles
ordinaires les plans les élèves qui sont
dans rien Patrice les élèves qui sont
dans rien c'est ça
je vais mettre plus de projets
particuliers encore alors les élèves qui
sont dans rien ça va être encore pire
non les élèves qui sont dans quelque
chose
donc pour tous les élèves qui sont dans
rien oui mais c'est ce que je souhaite
ça se fera pas demain matin d'abord les
projets faut qu'ils viennent des écoles
faut qu'ils viennent d'abord c'est pas
moi qui va arriver le qui va parachuter
des projets particuliers les d'ailleurs
dans notre Loi sur l'instruction
publique le projet éducatif par donner
le terme un peu technique mais le projet
éducatif ça doit venir du conseil
d'établissement soit ça veut dire
l'équipe école les enseignants bon les
parents puis au secondaire les élèves
siègent au conseil d'établissement il
faut qu'il me propose des projets
particuliers je leur dis là amenez-en
des projets particulier puis nous on va
vous aider à les créer puis on va vous
aider à les implanter dans vos écoles
puis l'objectif actuellement le patrice
il y a un petit peu plus que la moitié
des écoles secondaires qui ont déjà un
projet particulier au moyen bon ben moi
je souhaite qu'on se rapproche le plus
possible du 100% des écoles secondaires
une chose qui est plus concrète dans ce
que vous avez dit mais là il manque le
camp le camp mais vous dites la forme
mettons que j'ai je vais à l'enseigner
moi-même j'ai un bac universitaire mais
je vais aller enseigner je vois qu'il
manque d'enseignant ça me tente de faire
ça trois quatre ans cinq ans peu importe
mais j'ai pas envie d'aller faire un 60
crédits en éducation puis de quelques
années une formation en cours un
certificat d'un an 30 crédit vous avez
dit on va revenir à ça à quel moment on
va revenir à ça
le plus rapidement possible je vais vous
dire là je sais que c'est pas une
réponse que vous aimez c'est parce que
mon objectif là j'aimerais ça
annoncer dans les
j'aimerais ça qu'en septembre prochain
là on est déjà cette voix qui soit
ouverte peut-être pas pour tous ceux et
celles qui veulent y aller mais qu'on
puisse déjà
l'automne prochain dire à certaines de
ces personnes qui ont un bac en histoire
en français en anglais en mathématiques
en géographie qui ont le goût de devenir
enseignant cette voix-là vous est
offerte 30 crédits
donc mettons deux années à temps partiel
plutôt que 4 ou 5 années comme c'est le
cas présentement que la maîtrise
qualifiante vous pouvez déjà aller dans
les centres de service scolaire à être
un enseignant non légalement qualifié
mais au bout de deux ans avec cette voix
de 30 crédits vous allez devenir des
vrais enseignants avec un brevet
d'enseignant vous allez être légalement
qualifié on a besoin on a besoin c'est
bon ça c'est il manque le camp mais
c'est plus que c'est concret
le deuxième adulte dans la classe vous
dites vous m'en aviez parlé un peu il y
a quelques mois vous êtes la personne
par exemple qui est qui surveille les
services de garde l'éducatrice en
service de garde peut pourrait venir
donner un coup de main à l'enseignante
dans la classe pendant les heures ou à
surveille pas le service de garde c'est
ça là dont on parle et combien quand et
combien ça va se ça va être partout ça
idéalement dans toutes les écoles
primaires en tout cas dans toutes les
écoles primaires où il y a des
éducatrices en service de garde qui ont
des heures à donner puis moi je peux
vous le dire Patrice là c'est pas si
scientifique là mais quand je me promène
dans les écoles puis je demande aux
éducatrices aimeriez-vous ça
si entre le matin et puis le midi parce
que vous êtes au service de garde le
matin vous êtes au service de garde le
midi vous avez des heures entre les deux
aimeriez-vous ça aller dans les classes
puis aller prêter main forte et la
majorité me disent oui bien sûr qu'on
aimerait ça puis je dis entre le midi
puis la fin de la journée oui bien sûr
puis vous demandez aux enseignants là
puis je vous le dis Patrice c'est pas
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui j'ai trouvé que
la réaction de Madame Scalabrini de la
de la CSQ de la de la FSE qui est la
Fédération des enseignants au sein au
sein de la CSQ je l'ai trouvé
mettons qu'elle a un préjugé favorable à
cette idée-là dans sa réaction
maintenant oui ça doit être négocié dans
le cadre des conventions collectives
parce que vous comprendrez que si on
fait rentrer des éducatrices en service
de garde dans les classes
c'est des bidous ça là imaginez
vous demandez de la souplesse au
syndicats aussi
rénovation des Collières d'amande
Premier ministre nous amené dans une
école extraordinaire flambant neuf avec
du bois comme une oeuvre d'art il y en a
comme deux au Québec comme ça les autres
ont besoin beaucoup beaucoup d'amour il
y en a 60% qui ont besoin de
59 qui ont besoin de rénovation votre
PQI
programme québécois
d'infrastructures est-ce que le Conseil
du Trésor va vous donner beaucoup plus
d'argent pour accélérer les rénovations
qui coûtent de plus en plus cher et les
constructions d'école
c'est une excellente question mais
on gagne pas la dépense et ma priorité
mais oui je sais il faudrait que je vois
m’appuyer là-dessus pour aller plaider
auprès de mon collègue Jonathan Trudeau
qui est responsable du programme
québécois des infras justement
le PM dit c'est la priorité des
priorités déjà que le PQ a augmenté pour
les écoles et augmenter de 9 à 21
milliards en 4 ans c'est pas de la colle
9 à 21 milliards puis c'est pas assez
faut qu'il augmente encore davantage
pour que je puisse faire plus de
rénovation puis construire plus de
nouvelles écoles alors je vais plaider
auprès de Jonathan Trudeau pour
qu'effectivement il soit au rendez-vous
pour que je puisse bien plus de belles
écoles au Québec monsieur Drainville
merci on va attendre des annonces plus
concrètes pour le mieux enseigner le
français dès que vous avez des choses
concrètes vous êtes le bienvenu
s'intéresse tout le monde merci Patrice
la qualité de la langue merci au revoir
à la prochaine ouais on travaille on
travaille là-dessus merci